fall in love through sex men fall in
love through quality time and loyalty i
must be a man then
i want to just go back to that how what
do you consider a long-term relationship
um so my first was six years old
how old are you i'm 28 28. you're gone
uh my last one's gonna be three years
now
three years okay and then i had like a
one year one
so you had three long-term relationships
and you and you said that you you had
sex and you took it away because it
wasn't about no it was one of those
things where before i slept with them
that connection was kind of built first
like i had to trust that person and know
that
um it's not just going to be physical
there's going to be something more there
right that's what that's what i thought
you meant but i'm saying that's for you
i'm a man i would want to have sex with
you the moment i see you like it's like
it's not i don't i want to build a
connection and i want to get to know her
the more you make me wait the less i
probably want to um
that's a bit harsh to say
the the longer you make me wait the more
i want to be spiteful
yeah
see i want to be spanish
i want to be spiteful because you gave
it to that guy for in one on the one
night stand he wasn't he wasn't crap to
you yeah but me you saw me coming along
and you thought you know what
you know what i was like i'm not getting
dignity yeah
like okay i'm gonna be proper this time
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep it close i'm
gonna be proper and he's thinking wait
hold on a minute like
michael got it on day one like you
trying to make me wait four months yeah
all right wait till four months is done
and i've pre and i've pressed you now
we'll see when i've got my post not
clarity if i want to stay firstly that's
assuming
four months to get posted
and b so i've also spoken to a lot of
guys who say that when they sleep with
somebody straight away they tend to lose
a little bit of respect for them it
depends and then they no longer really
look at them as a long-term partner
because they thought okay this was
really easy so how many other
individuals is she sleeping
i think the question is is it genuine
because the thing is like what he's
referring to is a girl that gives and i
don't i don't know you maybe you've
never had a one night stand that's fine
but i'm saying well he's referring what
he's referring to is girls that give it
up on the first night for some guys and
then make another guy wait and so it's
kind of like to him well i had to put
all this investment where the other guy
just got it for free so it's really
frustrating to men because they feel
like you're not really attracted to them
because you gave it to the other guy
isn't it a compliment to them though
exactly
it shows
is taking you seriously perhaps no i
think i think that's like a woman's
point of view yeah yeah like like
i'm making you wait because i like you
please wait a few months until i feel
like sleeping with you it's a compliment
that's the assumption i'm making you
wait because i like myself yeah i think
women have a fear if they genuinely like
a guy
of
them being rejected okay so you're
saying the reason why you make me wait
is because if you think you give it to
me early i'm not going to respect you as
much as if you made me wait potentially
but then you disrespected me by giving
someone else no chance to wait why are
you doing your business comparing
yourself
because we're men we're we're very
territorial we're very competitive we're
very compe i don't want that i don't
want to have
intercourse with a girl that that's well
i don't want to be taking a woman
seriously when she's had um intercourse
with my friends yes men can't undo their
biology yeah and and the thing is um men
are but they're predispositioned to be
repulsed by women that sleeps around so
and the reason is because historically
they had to ensure paternity so if they
were wiping basically like wiping a hoe
back in the day they could be raising a
kid that's not theirs and even though we
have birth control nowadays you can't
undo their hard wiring so and the data
supports it because women that
have sex with one person and that's
their husband have an 80 chance of being
in a happy marriage and if they have
sleep with more than five people that
drops down to twenty percent after ten
years
wow but is that not contradictory to
what he just said about if you make
somebody wait then they kind of become
spiteful and but then you're saying
no it depends how you make me no but i'm
saying like it depends if it's genuine
is did the girl did the girl sleep with
20 dudes and then make him way or is she
a virgin and making him wait because
she's a virgin like there's two very
different ways to go about it but
when you kind of start dating somebody
you don't necessarily discuss your sex
life with that individual anyway so like
for example how would you know that i've
slept with x y and zed i would not get
to know you and i would know how
because okay you know woman's intuition
you know that feeling you get when it's
like nah this guy is cheating a man has
an intuition as well he could smell the
hole
he could smell it he could be like no
just like not stuck she'll be like i've
never done this before
your woman intuition isn't always
correct but
the majority of the time it's some point
it's on point so you know i like i might
not every girl i would second guess i'll
be like you know what i'm going with my
intuition not every time i'll be right
but majority of the times i'm right
because there's certain signals that
girls give off
when they tend to be more persecute um
what signals are there no no no no no no
no
that's what the men called no no no
there's no maintenance for the bothers
you're saying um signals women give up
about being more promiscuous yeah i'm
very open sexually um i grew up in
a family that was very like sex wasn't a
taboo subject my daughters i speak very
openly with freely with them about sex
and
i had slept with one person from i was
50 until i was 33 in a whole 18-year
relationship
and i was very open sexually but
i find that
some people will look at that as being
oh that you can openly talk about sex
and orgasms and things that they would
think
that's
she must be promiscuous because she can
talk about sex or she she loves me you
said no no i'm not i'm i didn't say no
no no no i said science you did i'm
saying to you
that's i think sometimes the signs might
be
misconstrued because absolutely i think
men think that women being open talking
about sex and
talking about orgasms being very like
sometimes smoking to another man
sometimes men are wrong you're right
like sometimes they don't guess
correctly but i just like the point is
that when men
realize that a girl has been ran through
it repulses them
and they can't help it it's their
biology yeah the same way women want a
guy that's taller than us because we
wanted a guy to protect us that's our
biology
but we're in control of body count men
aren't in control of height
yeah i agree
so
like you don't think okay
if your friend has done something yeah
that she wasn't supposed to do can't you
just feel it on her like she's just done
something like i like you i you can't
put your finger on it yeah but it's
something about your friend like no you
did something you did something with him
and it's like that intuition that men
has when you've been around enough women
to know like this there's just like
triggers that's like wait hold on i've
seen i've seen that before okay i'll
stop and i wouldn't immediately um
give her the um i'll give her the
benefit of doubt and be like okay that
was just one time and then i see another
one it's like
oh it's starting to compile now yeah so
when there's compiled now of certain
things that you look out for as a man to
know what like a promiscuous woman is
not necessarily the same as a woman
that's abstaining no i i hear what
you're saying because i mean i've met
men and i thought wow like you you as
you said about the protection i'm very
i'm a man's man
and i've initially thought yeah and then
saw wow
you're not about that life
and i've i do not have the same way
you're saying you can smell a hoe it's
like i can smell a [ __ ]
you like
so yeah i get what you're saying like
it's like you could tell like this guy's
faking it he's not really he's not
really really bad
he ain't alpha like yeah he's pretending
like you don't he does he says the right
things yeah but you could just tell the
bucket no no
so that's the intuition that men are
that men can see in girls and they're
like wait hold on i'm not going to let
her know that i know
i'm going to sleep with her first and
then i was just going to ghost or i'm
going to go with her friend or i'm going
to do do you want to i'm just going to
um keep on sleeping with her and not
give her a relationship
i'm going
to say he would do things
other than make you his wifey to be
walking on road with you holding hands
so everyone else could see yeah but then
if we make you wait that's an issue as
well
it depends who if you're all right if
you've had um intercourse with someone
in the scene
london is a very small place and a big
place at the same time please be
guaranteed that i know at least three
people that you've you've you've
not necessarily slept with but you was
talking to or you was doing things with
if i could tell by the caliber of guy
that you're around what you're saying
and i'm speaking to these guys because
men talk to each other on a you like man
just needs to give another guide a
little wink like
that's you mighty like do you know what
to say girls they do it as well yeah we
do you know what i'm saying girls give
girls the look like men do things to let
men know eggs don't go there that's me
so so just to understand
you're either
the girl that you're going to end up
with has either got to be a saint that's
not slept around and makes you wait
or she's got an open sex life unless she
has sex with you straight away she's not
good enough either so what is your no no
ideology
you're trying to put me in the corner
without continually i'm trying to
understand what it is
i'll make you understand
if you are accustomed to sleeping around
yeah and then you find that one guy that
you're really interested in want to make
him think that i'm a good girl and he's
going to like me i'm going to put my
best foot forward and i'm gonna make him
wait and do that he already knows no no
no no i already know what you're on
i've already seen the whole play already
i'm not coming to you ma'am you have an
only fan yeah like you know what i'm
trying to say like i've don't think the
first time i'm coming to you is the
first time i've seen you i've already
got the play oh what's what's maria
saying okay all right all right what did
you not do the thing yeah what mine was
that okay what she's on that yeah all
right say no more same okay let me let
me hold maria when i see maria hi maria
you're right you're so beautiful i love
you you know what i'm saying it was
angel i love you so much look you in the
eyes and talk to you in your ears and
whisper and stuff i'll make you think
i'm like you know what i'm saying like
i'm i'm not being genuine but i'm being
genuine if you get what i'm saying i'm
interested but i'm not going to take you
as seriously you could tell me from a
guy's point of view you want to be the
guy that she breaks rules for yeah like
she made everyone else wait but she
slept with you right away and you're not
the guy she's doing it for is it nice
but then on the other hand
is it say that again isn't it nice to do
the opposite as well though like maybe
she slept around a load of guys but she
wants to take it slow with you because
she really loves her
okay no no no no
i want to hear from every guy in this
room is that nice
no
i didn't hear what you said she said if
you do the opposite she sleeps with
everyone and takes it slow with you i
want to hear from everyone in the room
wait wait wait wait if she's wife
material surely i don't get that what do
you mean
isn't it nice to have rules broken for
you
so if a woman sleeps around a lot yeah
yeah then she meets you and she's like
right i want to i want to get him to be
my husband i want to take things slow
yeah
isn't that a sign to you that she really
likes you and is invested so what if she
likes me i don't care if she really
likes me
one thing to do with me liking you i've
already disqualified you because i know
what you're like but you know what i
think
so you say that you would your friend
would give you the lowdown yeah she's at
home and then you're gonna buckle and
say yeah well go on maria um let's go
out on a date but really all you want to
do is smash no not date
who's the date wow well it's like
whether you want whether it's a smash
date or a dinner day or whatever you
want to smash but then you're not being
transparent so then because you're not
telling that you just want to smash no
but a lot of girls like he doesn't take
them out on a date he doesn't treat them
like a girlfriend and then they sleep
together and then she's mad
because he doesn't wife her but he never
was he never they weren't dating
intentionally anyway i never told her i
want to be your wife i want you to be my
wife i didn't say that i'm just chilling
with you and we happen to have
intercourse i'm not taking it seriously
i don't understand why why is it so bad
for a man to be sexually active as much
as a woman sexually active and have the
freedom to be sexually active and not
only that but
you see really it isn't it isn't just
because i'm not saying you're not
allowed to be sexually active i'm just
saying you can't be sexually active with
me i hate what you're saying i hit like
okay that's not what you want to write
but i think like
what you just said was the total
reversal of what we know is true like
it's okay for you guys to be hosed but
as soon as a woman has slipped around
yeah it's because men and women are
different it's a double standard no it's
definitely that's what i'm saying
you said it like in terms of what
because if if if your girlfriend's man
slept around you're not going to be like
it's all right darling like it's me no
i'm not right so there we go so let's
not make it out like i was i was brought
up by a man i was raised by my dad so i
was instilled early into me that what
what we think of women who [ __ ] around
because after my mom passed away all my
dad did was [ __ ] around
so i soon got to see how women that
[ __ ] up got treated so
i knew that from the start and i
wouldn't be happy for my daughters to
sleep around that is what's instilled in
me all right it's like this
digger
a male gold digger yeah is looked at
worse than a female gold digger as in
that show what was that show called 100
the um
swindler the thing that girls do every
single day on this earth he was
dishonest
every day what are you talking about he
was the the tinder swindler
built on women scamming men online
because one in three men under the age
of 30 hasn't had sex in the past year or
is a virgin one in three men
yeah so
so there are entire industries built off
of women doing webcam and that sort of
thing
getting money and extracting money off
of men that's how andrew tate made his
money that's why he's a
multi-multi-millionaire and nobody bats
an eye nobody cares when it's a guy and
they say you should have known better
but with the women they get a whole
goddamn documentary yeah but they're
getting something out of it it's a
transaction all right let me also no no
because they'll sell him the dream
that's what they do and like like andrew
tate like breaks this down where they
will literally
convince these guys that one day they're
gonna meet one day they're going to
sleep together one day one day one day
and like this happens every day no one
cares maybe the women are watching
disney so okay
maybe maybe the girls in the tinder
swindler should stop watching disney
absolutely
but i'm saying people did fundraisers
they were raising money for these women
yeah but to me i'm like that was your
own damn fault why on earth would anyone
donate to that and that's what i would
say to the guys too but for the men they
do it yeah like they don't nobody cares
the women people care
differently your heart is hungry you eat